All right.
Do we have everybody?
We have everybody.
Mr. CFO, I I'll passing the reigns to you. Bhanssky.
Hello. Rhensky here. Um I'm just Mr. CFO. I'm just telling you
how it is and what to do. Um
we lost $3,500.
Why? Why did we do that? Why? Why did you do that?
Yeah.
>> For 2 years, a man calling himself Peasants Ambition
has been producing a show. He documents his attempt to become
a professional day trader, streaming his journey to an audience
that can often be counted on one hand. The show is about one
thing, failure.
>> A year and a half of complete and utter
It's failure because the bottom line, you didn't make money.
You lost money.
And honestly, the bottom line's all that freaking matters, dude.
It's all that matters.
And all I've done was lose.
This isn't a cautionary tale. This is a log book of financial
self- emilation broadcast live for no one to see.
The series pilot aired in late 2023.
The protagonist, a data analyst, makes a lifealtering decision,
believing his command of numbers gives him an edge >> full-time.
I quit my job as a data analyst for a healthcare company
um in October of last year and I started trading um my savings
and my home equity line of credit.
And this is the story of trading my $51,000.
Um, this is,
spoiler alert,
uh, bad.
The show was capitalized with his personal savings and critically
by leveraging his primary residence for a $51,000 line of credit.
The premise was simple. A man of logic applies his skills to
the market and wins.
The initial data sets, however, were uncooperative.
The plot of the show quickly veered from a steady rise to a series
of shocking downward spikes. These weren't minor setbacks. They
were account crippling events performed live.
in one day. I lost $18,000
on December 19th. This is so much money, bro. in one day.
16th, it looks like I lost $17,000 in one day. You can see it.
It's very small, but that's what it was. Um,
I wish I had recorded that. I looked all over for the recordings.
I looked all over for this. Um, it doesn't seem like anybody
but God saw this one.
ended up losing freaking 20 grand that day.
So, Friday.
Um,
I hate talking about it, dude.
I hate talking about it, but whatever. >> A $20,000 loss
in a single day, a quarterly salary for some, just another episode
for the channel. The losses all stemmed from the same recurring
bugs in his own code. >> Brokerage account. I've lost 20
grand in a day, dude.
It's so
It's so dangerous. It's so dark.
I've made 20 grand in a day.
It's just I
uh $10,000
loss on that one one position. About about that much. One $10,000
loss. I'm surprised the brokerage let me have it that let that
far down.
And then it goes into my buy zone. Right as my buy zone, I it
exits me cuz I have no control over it anymore cuz it I have
no money left. >> These bugs weren't mysterious. He was
in fact the world's leading expert on his own fatal flaws. He
documented them with the precision of an engineer analyzing a
catastrophic failure. and I escalated risk after a loss. That
was huge. I noticed that that was a direct I have it all written
in my my trade ledger. Um I have every trade documented and I
see that
when I lose I risk more. You can easily see that it's a retaliation.
You can easily see the correlation between losing and risk going
up. And I did do that. It escalates. What I did was it went towards
my stop loss. I said I'm dragging my stop loss all the way down.
all the way down. I've lost so much money is buying after I lost
the same dip. It's still dipping. It's still dipping. It hasn't
even breathed upwards yet. Off this is push down. You know, I'm
in the smaller time frames, 5 minutes, and I see this. It's still
going down. He meticulously cataloged the core programming of
his failure. >> Mistakes is number one, um
moving my stop loss further away. Number
adding to a loser.
Number three,
escalating risk after a loss. Okay, all those three helped me
lose all the money that I have lost. He knew the problem. He
just couldn't stop running the faulty script.
To resolve the conflict between his intelligence and his results,
he developed a new operating system for his worldview. The problem
wasn't him. It was the market source code. It was
>> If there's anything consistent about the market is that
it's inconsistent in any ways, even if you do all the things
you might not win. You might not even it might not even be profitable.
It's just crazy to me. Um,
and I think
it's really difficult to find any edge at all. And the edge that
we do find that I have found
might not work in the future. >> His solution was a clever
software patch for the ego. If the market punishes logic, then
logic must be abandoned. The only winning move is to embrace
the
>> If the market's telling me one thing, we do the freaking
opposite, bro. We do the opposite. And there's an
It sucks. It's weird.
Um, and it's a risk, but >> this patch allowed him to override
his own trading plans in real time, executing trades directly
contrary to his system based on a feeling.
>> Um, but I saw the long and I actually said, I'm going
to exactly do opposite of this. >> It became a self-reinforcing
loop. He'd design a system, it would fail, and that failure would
prove his thesis that the only constant is chaos, justifying
the next irrational bet.
I'm telling you, it was really good one year,
you know, and made risking five grand a trade. It made 60 grand
the year. I'm like, wow, that is an excellent system. The next
year, I lose 20 grand. What the hell is going on? As the losses
mounted, the show's content shifted. He began a new story arc,
framing his behavior not as trading, but as something else. He
even produced a special episode applying a clinical framework
to his own actions. >> Yo, what's good? What is good? Today
I'm going to be talking about the three C's of an addiction.
He checked the boxes.
Intense cravings and overwhelming compulsion to chase
What am I feeling now that I lost 20 grand? Oh, what I'm feeling
is like I need to make it back, bro. I was at 30 grand in my
account. Now I'm at 10.
My life.
so what do I have to do? I I'm feeling cravings. I'm feeling
like I can't wait till Sunday evening where I can place a trade
and bet the entire freaking account to So I I'm
I'm driving. I'm like I can't wait for Sunday night.
Isn't that cravings? I never thought I know I have loss of control
when trading
Um but I didn't think I had uh cravings
and I think that this is cravings. uh continued use despite negative
and almost numb acceptance of financial
>> and continued use after freaking um negative negative
effects. Dude, I've lost a ton of money, bro. I've lost so much.
It's It's getting It's like not intense. I'm like, I if I had
lost that much,
I'd be like
like pulling my hair out cuz but I've lost so much that I don't
even care as much. >> And finally, loss of control where
the plan is discarded in favor of a single desperate roll of
the dice. >> Start here. I want to start
I'd rather just gamble and then run the system when I get back
to 30 grand or 20 grand. Just give me 20. Just let me gamble
my way up to 20. I've done it that so many times.
It can happen. I bet it's It is a 50/50 chance. You risk 10 grand.
I risk my entire account. >> After a year and a half of
content creation, the show reached its season finale. The account
balance hit zero.
>> I've lost all of my money. I have a helock
and it's gone. I have I am truly a skeleton. And now I have to
reach out to my family to bail me out,
get another job, and go back to working.
Not quite my favorite thing to do. Um, I just find it
upsetting that
I can work a
easy McGee jo.
Everything's fine. The final monologue of the season wasn't one
of acceptance. It was a bug report filed against the universe.
I am supposed I I put effort in and I get nothing out. What is
the laws of the universe? You work hard and you get paid. Where's
my pay?
You go.
Where's my pay? You're letting me down. You
have to go back to this stupid job where it means nothing.
The data analyst had run the numbers. The ROI on his effort was
negative. He would have been more profitable turning off his
brain and clocking in. >> I take my risk and I'm doing
this and
it's just dude
I would be better off just turning my brain off and working at
Jo O.
How is that more rewarding than what I've done?
I'm wasting my energy at stupid jo O. I'm wasting my energy
wasting my damn energy on someone else's
that's how life is.
Nobody said it was easy. This should be where the credits roll.
But for a content creator, the end of one season is just the
setup for the next. The show hasn't been cancelled. >> That
tells me in back of my head is that this story is not over.
We're halfway through, bro.
But that's the problem. Because if you still have hope that trading
can work, still have this hope. You're still striving at it.
You can't continue red bars. You cannot continue losing money.
>> He's not quitting. He's planning a reboot. He'll get
a job, grind for capital, and relaunch the series from the beginning.
I don't think I'm going to give up.
I'm working a job to save up money to redo this year. I want
a redo. I want a redo. I want a redo, man.
Just give me a redo, bro. I would treat this so much differently.
I would never put money in a trading brokerage account. I would
not have a brokerage account. I would just use prop firms. I
would use prop firms with the smallest amount of risk possible.
He frames his stubbornness as his greatest asset, a feature,
not a bug, an unshakable belief in his own delusional reality.
>> I know. How do you think that?
I have a faith that is really, really, really, really hard to
that's why.
>> And so for his handful of viewers, the story will go
on. The evidence of his failure is total. The financial damage
is catastrophic.
And yet, the producer, director, and star of the show remains
committed to his crap. All I can say is that I have tried and
I'm not done.
Yeah, I'll go get a job, but deep in heart my heart and deep
in my mind,
I'm just going through the motions until I can get back and um
do this right. He will continue to generate content.
He will continue to document the damage. He will continue moving
forward because that's what the show's
>> No matter how much damage I take, I'm just going to
keep moving forward
and until life is over. That's just life,